[Music]
time dedication and fairness that is how
a group of volunteers describe being on
the fuse of force board for metro police
8 news now has taken a look at the state
of the department in a week-long series
the i-team's vanessa murphy is live with
this report vanessa
brian these are volunteers who might get
a call in the middle
of the night to go to a scene and police
might have one perspective on force
being used but
these are outsiders representatives from
the community
who weigh in i was struck by
um i heard that there wasn't that they
had never had an officer motion that was
ruled
um not or inappropriate or wrong and i
said how can i be that there's no way
that
100 percent know that was during the
days of the coroner's
inquest viewed by many as one-sided
hearings about use of force
incidents at the hands of officers
critics said it led officers
off the hook and the clark county
commission heard from community members
like rhonda gibson
in 2011 her husband stanley an unarmed
war veteran
was shot and killed by metro police i
don't want my husband's death to be in
vain
in 2013 six members of the use of force
board
resigned the board which was created in
the 90s reviews use of force incidents
at the hands of police
then sheriff doug gillespie went against
board recommendations
and refused to fire an officer who shot
an
unarmed man he survived the board found
the officer had mistaken the sight of a
shiny sticker on a hat
for the medal of a gun as sheriff i have
the last say in these matters
internally motion passes that same year
the commission ruled
to end the inquest now in addition to a
public fact-finding review where
information is publicly released the use
of force board holds more weight to
decide whether an incident is justified
one recent example after the in-custody
death of an
unarmed black man byron williams in
2019.
the use of force board identified
problems with how officers handled
williams
and what followed at the scene the metro
police department
then made policy changes the board
includes four commissioned officers
and three citizens from a pool of 20
which
donovan britt david skelton and richard
metzler
are part of i would say the majority of
our cases that i've served on this year
haven't even haven't
involved the use of a gun it's been
other issues where the
the person died going hands-on what's
important to
myself and probably every member of the
board is transparency
it's what we look for there has to be
someone on that bridge that people can
trust and say look
i was in that room this is what i saw i
was on the scene i spoke to the chief we
spoke as a group together
and i'm telling you this is how this
case went now at the same time there
also has to be that that notion that we
can be critical
and supportive at the same time
tonight at 11 we'll take a closer look
at the in-custody death of byron
williams and we'll also take a look
at the number of use of force incidents
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now